how to launch a product when you know
nothing about launching a product
so i got a great question from our
youtube viewers love you guys rafaela
who wrote in to say
help marketing my new product i caught
your youtube video launching a new
product i was wondering if you could
help me in any way
i have a great product that i need help
with launch into the marketplace
i'm great at the food development but
know nothing about how to get it to the
next stages
it's a product called bark scotty it's
an organic blueberry biscotti for
dogs that offers a complete protein and
is green dairy meat and gluten free
thank you rafaela so this is a common
problem for a lot of entrepreneurs where
you
are great at creating something you're
an inventor you've created this great
product or this great service and you're
great at delivering it
but the marketing and the sales is
something that you're not good at you
have no interest in
and without that it's hard to grow a
business
and so you have two options here rafaela
the first
is you try to do everything yourself
you try to learn the marketing try to
learn the sales and you're handling
everything in your business you're
handling the product development the
the sourcing the customer service and
the sales and marketing
and it can work the challenge is you're
spread too thin
and you're forced to do things that
maybe you have no interest in maybe
you're not good at maybe you wish
you didn't have to do it all and you
could focus on the product development
the second option is to find a partner
you partner up with somebody who loves
doing all that stuff
can help your business grow and you
focus on the things that you're really
good at and you love doing
that's probably the preferred option for
you
if you don't want to learn all of that
sales and marketing stuff yourself
so how do you find a partner how do you
find somebody to buy into your business
love what you're all about and help take
you where you need to go
the first is start hanging around your
industry
so start going to trade shows and events
and being involved
maybe you're a speaker maybe you're an
exhibitor but at least being there
and knowing and meeting people who are
around your industry so it could be
your direct competition but it could
also be customers and suppliers and
those trade shows have lots of different
types of vendors who are going and just
getting to know people
and letting them know what you're about
leads to opportunities
numbers two start letting your network
know what you're looking for
when i had my first software company we
had a great product
uh just like you you feel you have a
great product we felt we had a great
product but it wasn't getting out there
we felt like we needed help
i had no connections nobody you know i
was 19 years old
i didn't know where to go to i went to
my bank you know the banks they're
supposed to be the friends of
entrepreneurs right so i went to my bank
and i said here's what i'm doing can you
help me somehow
and obviously the bank that's not their
business but i didn't know it at the
time
but they put me in touch with a
consultant that they had used and that
consultant
put me in touch with somebody else who
put me in touch with somebody else and
that person ended up
really being a driving force to help our
business go forward
and it all started with me just letting
my network know and and the bank wasn't
even in my network i just showed up one
day and said hey you're my banker
can you help me so it's getting the word
out the people who you want to talk to
in your network are the people who are
connected
to a lot of business type of people and
those are going to be
your lawyer your accountant financial
advisor
insurance broker all of these people
talk to
other entrepreneurs and may be in touch
with somebody who is looking for an
opportunity
to join a business and help it grow so
you have to get the word out
okay those are the first two third you
can also go and look for
people who are experts at this and who
are writing and talking about this so
look for people who are writing
about getting dog food launched and
getting dog food placed
at costco or any of the big retailers
in america right look for those people
and you can reach out to them
and either they may come on and ask for
a fee i don't know if you can afford
that or not they may be intrigued enough
with your business to do something on a
commission basis or they may like it
enough that they become your partner
in your business and it's reaching out
to these guys and putting your name on
the map that's the key
right it's getting out there and talking
to people in your industry
and talking to people who are in your
network who may connect you to people
and talking to people who are experts
are selling into big companies selling
pet food into those distribution
networks talking to those people
and getting your name on their radar and
i know that's scary
and stepping outside your comfort zone
but what's your alternative the
alternative used to do everything
yourself
and is that something that you want to
do and if you don't get this help
where does that leave your company you
know you know you're sitting on this
great product
and it's not getting out there so if you
don't get this help
what happens to your business and
hopefully that's
a reason enough to help you step
out of that fear step outside your
comfort zone
and start connecting with people who can
help make a impact with your business
believe those are watching i'd love to
know what you think about finding
partners
leave it in the comment section below if
you like these videos you can support me
by clicking on the link in the
description
and click on my face to subscribe to the
channel thank you so much
i'll see you soon